hey guys i'm ryan right and i Breanna
white there you go yes you're cute don't
know why guests never don't want to say
their name it's pretty obvious okay
we're gonna check out from top trending
ten real-life deaths caused by video
games Brianna's gonna be starting up a
youtube channel which features gaming on
it so I thought this is a great video to
watch her okay here we go
in 2007 16 year old Daniel Patrick shot
both of his parents over a disagreement
about halo 3 after his open fire just
the game against their wishes they took
it away and locked it in the home safe
Daniel found the key to unlock the safe
unfortunately his game was right next to
a gun reacting on impulse Daniel grabbed
the gun he then snuck up behind his
parents and said would you close your
eyes I have a surprise for you then he
shot them both killing his mother and
critically injuring his father after
Daniel shot both of his parents he then
put the gun in his father's hand so he
could make it look like a murder-suicide
as the police arrived on scene they
found Daniel trying to flee in the
family van with the halo 3 game in the
passenger's seat because of his age
Daniel could not have been given the
death penalty he was given life in
prison and won't be eligible for parole
until 2032 in 2012 an 18 year old only
known as Truong died at an internet cafe
in Taiwan after reportedly playing the
video game Diablo 3 for 40 hours
straight and attended at the cafe found
Chuang resting on the table next to his
computer the attendant woke him up
Chuang then stood up took a few steps
and then collapsed onto the ground he
was pronounced dead soon after arriving
at the hospital his death was due in
part to a blood clot in his leg
presumably from sitting in front of that
computer too long oh my god company over
Diablo released a statement that said we
feel that moderation
is clearly important and that a person's
day-to-day life should take precedence
over any form of entertainment a 17-year
old Philippine scene murdered his own
grandmother
after she interrupted his dota match the
teen had been playing defense of the
ancients in a neighborhood internet cafe
his grandmother who told him not to play
that game anymore
went to pick him up and return him to
their home when the woman began scolding
him about the game he alleges that he
blacked out and beat his 68 year old
grandmother to death the team cleaned up
the bloody crime scene and called his
aunt who then called the police the
victim was found with wounds on her neck
chest head and arms police officers also
found blood-stained ceramic shards of
what appeared to be a smashed vase in a
garbage bin in the front yard the
grandmother who had raised the boy since
early childhood on her own was killed
because the boy wanted to play a video
game South Korean man Elysees own soul
wasn't just an avid player of StarCraft
he was addicted to it he let the popular
real-time strategy game take control
over his entire life in 2005 he started
spending all of his time playing the
game which cost him his job and longtime
girlfriend Lee would spend almost all of
his money in an internet cafe to play it
he was used to playing 14 to 18 hour
sessions but when he started a 50 hour
session that was the end of his gaming
days at the end he collapsed and died
from exhaustion and dehydration when it
comes to games there's a difference
between healthy and Juji azzam and an
unhealthy addiction in this case the
man's love for StarCraft consumed him
seventeen-year-old warren leblanc of
leicestershire england got life in
prison for emulating a death scene in a
video game in 2004 the game in question
manhunt
the game was developed by Rockstar North
armed with a knife and a claw hammer
Warren lured 14 year old Stefan pachira
to a nearby park he bludgeoned and
stabbed the boy over 50 times until he
died in the trial the mother of the
victim was forced to leave the room
as details of her son's horrific murder
were explained to the court at the end
of the proceedings the judge stated one
thing is clear you and you alone were
responsible for this prolonged vicious
and murderous attack on someone who
thought of you as a friend in 2013 an
8-year old Louisiana boy intentionally
shot and killed 87 year-old Mary
smothers his own grandmother the event
happened only minutes after the boy
started playing Grand Theft Auto
authorities believe he intentionally
shot mrs. smothers in the back of the
head as she sat in her living room
watching television family and friends
of the victim have stated that the
victim in the juvenile had a normal
loving relationship and even shared the
same bedroom the Sheriff's Department
released a statement saying
investigators have learned that the
juvenile suspect was playing Grand Theft
Auto for just minutes before the
homicide occurred the boy now living
with his parents won't face charges
under Louisiana law a child younger than
ten is exempt from criminal
responsibility whoa
eighteen-year-old Devin Moore was
actually arrested for grand theft auto
not the game the real-life crime in 2003
while being processed at the police
station he lunged at one of the officers
and grabbed his 40 caliber Glock he shot
him and two other police officers in the
head as he made his way out of the
station to then steal a police cruiser
once caught and handcuffed Moore uttered
life is a video game
you've got to die sometime in the truck
Oh his defense team tried to use the
rockstar game Grand Theft Auto Vice City
as a scapegoat for the young man's
violent acts ultimately Devin was
sentenced to death by lethal injection
in 2014 an 11-year old boy
in the Philippines was stabbed to death
by a 16 year old male allegedly the 11
year old victim hacked into the older
teens online dota 2 account according to
the family and police investigations the
victim was taken to a construction site
where he was beat up by the suspects his
head was slammed on the walls repeatedly
before being stabbed over 40 times the
16 year old suspect denied any
contact with the victim however he was
found with heavily blood-stained shorts
and drops of blood leading up to his
house the stabbing was so horrific that
the mother couldn't recognize her own
son 28 year old Philadelphia Mint Thomas
Spellman be his 17 month-old daughter to
death in 1602 the room and accidentally
toppled over his x-box breaking it in a
fit of rage Spellman repeatedly beat the
child
investigators contest that the child's
battered body was then positioned next
to a barbell in another room to make the
death look like an accident
Spellman fled the scene but turned
himself in the next day official autopsy
reports indicate that the toddler's
skull had been shattered and caved in by
continued blows to the head Spellman who
was a self-admitted video game addict
claimed that he did not intend to kill
the child he was sentenced to 22 to 45
years in prison in 2005 Payton leutner
was stabbed 19 times and left to die in
the middle of the woods the culprits
responsible for the attempted murder
were two of Payton's close friends
12-year old Morgan geyser and 13
year-old Anissa wire the two girls were
trying to please a fictional video game
character Slenderman they thought that
if they sacrificed a real person to
haunt them or hurt their families
according to court documents they told
detectives they had been planning to
stab her for months
investigators discovered more than 60
drawings of slender man in Geysers
bedroom one drawing depicted a girl
lying on the ground and a person
standing over her with the message I
love killing people once the bear lured
Payton into the woods one of the girls
pounced on her and started to stab her
repeatedly during the entire ordeal the
victim was screaming in agony and saying
I hate you guys I'll never forgive you I
trusted you once the attack was over the
girls ran away miraculously Payton
survived the attack and crawled her way
to a nearby trail where she was
discovered by a cyclist leutner has made
an amazing recovery
the attempted murder and as of this year
the girl who came within a whisper of
death celebrated her 13th birthday
extended on a decent yeah awful that was
really hard to get through oh no that
one time I saw a video called top 5
creepiest 9/11 one phone calls I've
heard about that
yeah I did not post it cuz they were
like real phone calls this I don't know
I guess I'm gonna post it because their
reports they're not like actual phone
calls and they you don't see footage of
any real things really dark it's dark
information but it's still really
haunting don't get me wrong I don't feel
good I'm almost conflicted about posting
okay but to be fair some of those video
games can't necessarily be blamed on the
video game like you can't say Grand
Theft Auto causes people to be violent
it's the passion about it that caused
them to be violent just like passionate
about our relationship how many deaths
is that cause ya know I think that video
games get such a bad rap sometimes for
inducing violent behavior but that's not
necessarily true there's a lack of
responsibility that people take on
everyone has this thing where they blame
people for [ __ ] they yeah it's like just
because they blame the video game does
not make the video game responsible yeah
one that really freaked me out though
was the slender one yeah that one [ __ ]
they were like worshiping slender like
it was [ __ ] insane
yeah cuz you know when you see about
people with the addiction to like
Starcraft or some online game that's an
addiction you know but people can get
addicted to anything
totally you know it's like we need food
but there are food addicts who are now
really obese and everything don't eat or
don't eat yeah people can get addicted
to anything and like the father who
killed his 17 month old yeah I'm not
gonna blame the video game it's like
there's clearly something
psychologically [ __ ] up with this guy
prior to this video game existing to why
he did it you can't blame the game we
even said he didn't mean to do it it's a
crime of passion and that's why they
have different categories
yeah exactly I gotta say though about
the video I know that they were trying
to keep it as short as possible but I
really needed some space between all
those stories to dislike is pretty dark
stuff be ready to like take a deep
breath the first time on my channel
first time on the channel yeah this is
what I like I thought it might be like a
funny video for some reason I didn't
think it was gonna be like oh this
psychologically [ __ ] up person played
a video game and then murder someone I
that was worse than like most episodes
of like Dateline really anytime oh yeah
that was pretty ah that's pretty bad oh
yeah video games have age ratings for a
reason yeah totally yeah because a
certain age should be able to handle
exactly I mean what was that one story
about the 11 year old and the 16 year
old who you know they were they're too
young to be playing that game anyway
yeah or that eat your oldest illness but
like you know you got to think that the
reason that these games are inspiring
these crimes I mean maybe they're just
not old enough to be seeing these types
of things and they're so impression of
all and they don't know how to handle it
processes information cuz like the video
games act as a catalyst to what happened
but anything could have been a catalyst
told us like if the guy didn't kill his
baby because of a video game it would
have something else if if the kid didn't
have a disagreement with his parents
over halo 3 that would have been over
something else anybody killed yeah they
led with a hard one
yeah that was I was like oh I can only
manage on the next nine or getting
together that was a rough start with
that one I know you don't want if
there's one thing I've learned yet don't
start off rough eventually and you get a
little rougher gets better metaphor this
whole anyway guys thanks for tuning in
to the channel thanks for putting us
through that too if you're new to the
video channel this is you can subscribe
to the real rejects Brianna white she is
gonna be starting up a youtube channel
already has shot some footage of it so
subscribe to her channel for now and
keep a lookout from videos are posted
and in the meantime if you want to look
got some cool stuff for Brianna go to
her Facebook page
what's it called exactly its
facebook.com slash Brianna white actress
yeah there's a good photos on there
supposedly I might have to check out
your Facebook sometime
yeah you should it's all sorts of
updates about my my acting stuff too any
movies I have coming out I'd definitely
post on that right but there's like ones
where you're like modeling right yeah
okay we did this bit in the last video
we did modeling photos keep a lookout
take a look you're confident we even got
a little fan blow before you give a
little wave effect here and you can
follow the real rejects on Facebook
Instagram Twitter vine and periscope and
her to you on all that [ __ ] John guy if
someone asked me do you have friends I
say yes I do and their names are Ryan
and Dan Veronica and Selena Sally and
brandy and Jeri and Alyssa and if you
guys give me a shout-out that'll be nice
if not it's okay still love you and
thanks for your time John guy sorry that
Briana is none of those people okay this
is your fault
let's come over on Tuesday yeah yeah
it's okay Briana it's okay John guy
listen my friend hmm okay one time I ran
into a problem with an actress where the
videos have to be taken down because the
manager didn't approve of my humor